I'm ready let's do this oh it's wrong  what did you do  okay welcome back to a new season of  Lost in Translation  I can't even read the English March nine  large seeds into the Super Bowl this is  just too much to process as usual we  take a recipe we put it into Google  Translate and there are going to be a  ton of surprises this season that's  printing out the hymn but the snow is  divided and there is a woman of seven  large beds having a lot of fun actually  so make sure to tune in every single  week so you don't miss out wow what okay  this is not going well wait do I get on  your hints cute shirts everyone thank  you you were already on the right track  are you kidding season two baby